whoa they spin stop maybe there was
maybe put a little too much ad yeah
maybe hey what's going on everybody four
first we feast I'm Sean Evans and today
we say so long to season four of hot
ones at long last I'm joined at the
table by my hill running partner chili
Klaus you know him as the Michael Jordan
of internet chili eating the Sultan of
scovilles the man who never met a
Carolina Reaper he couldn't snap his way
through a chili Klaus my hot pepper
brother-in-arms welcome to the table and
thank you ever do thank you very much
it's a pleasure to be here into the hot
ones fans out there this probably looks
like a typical setup a familiar thing
going on we have the wings we have the
sauces we have the water we have the
milk we have a guest
but when chili Klaus is in town you know
we have to crank the thing up to 14 it's
the double black diamond of the wings of
death chili Klaus are you game yeah
[Music]
now what we have here are five pepper
mashes okay the super hots came from our
friend smokin ed curry this morning and
then Noah made it in the back so these
are fresh no [ __ ] no frills it's a
chicken wing gauntlet unlike any other
do not try this at home
[Music]
this is so exciting I've never tried
this before it's a first for me as well
okay Nate can be very good afterwards
but I don't think it fits in a English
in a show well listen when chili Klaus
is in town it's chilly Klaus is rules
Schoenberger we got to lose this stuff I
regret this let me just take the milk is
gone regrettably so this first one is a
Serrano chili so you have some vinegar
you have some salt yeah you have some
butter just to make it stick to the wing
yeah but otherwise we're just straight
pepper with this one that's cool that's
that's fine
a little bit more spider than I expected
for Serrano but me as well until a class
or going places today yeah we always do
so chili Klaus your friend and you're a
familiar face to the audience here at
first we feast and to our audience we've
talked about the origin story of half
one's a million times but we've never
discussed yours chili Klaus how did
eating peppers become your life's
mission I'd love to know pebbles all my
life and I had a kick on a little island
for two months and when you have a gig
on an island you can come home every day
so I've brought all my chili peppers
with me and I put up a camera and it's a
chili pepper and put it on the internet
and boom after that day I was sure chili
sauce when you first started putting
videos on the internet did you read the
comments chili Klaus what do you feel
like when people say rude things does it
make you upset
no I'm getting used to it
I saw Jane - you had with Ricky Gervais
and you said something as I remember
it's like a person going here's a kisser
listen you don't have to open the door
into the kids a lesson
room and say just pass on why do you
think you get so many politicians on
your show because here in the United
States
I don't think any politician wouldn't
ever dare sit at the hot ones seat I
wonder what you think is different you
know why because on the first page in
the book of politician says never ever
cry on television my first kiss was
actually the mayor from the city where I
come from oh and the first time he was
acting like a politician and I said to
him don't be like a politician he be
yourself and he agreed and ten minutes
after he was puking on the lane near
Alice so it's so great and he still the
mayor in the city where I live so that's
cool all right chilly class ready to
move on the next thing is so ding ding
ding ding
[Music]
here when you're just going with this
straight mash you're gonna get a little
more kick without raw product they'll
put in a sauce chili I got you I'm gonna
be on that mmm so before we lose our
tongues today chili Klaus I'm hoping
that I can get a master class and the
Danish language rosetta stone lesson
from chili Klaus so I'll give you some
phrases and I'm hoping that you can tell
me how to say them in Danish does that
sound good yeah yeah yeah how do you say
can I have this dish extra spicy can ya
put in here cut extra stack slow it down
for me one time can ya can ya foot in
here cut 14 here hot extra extra stack
stack stack is hot how do you say excuse
me where is the nearest restroom it's an
emergency
once group whoa yeah T now mr. toilet
behind moose you don't show what yeah
yeah that's it toilet mija mija aim in
Surat sure no sir I zone yeah you're
doing so good that's so cool what's the
worst Danish swear word that you can
teach me without soiling the prestige of
the Klaus name yeah it could be for him
for hell Ville yeah that means damn it
can I say this yeah class I think you're
getting away with that without this
table yeah yeah and then finally I know
that you have a catchphrase that loosely
translates to you can feel it in your
ears yeah yeah can you explain that one
for me there's some connection between
the mouth and you use and if it's very
hard it goes right to my ears and
sometimes to my arms too but mostly to
my ears
does that let you snap remember why were
you snapping I think maybe because I
lose control over my body because it's
so hard yeah it starts having its own
language in a way and you can also feel
it it in you yes you know in my neck
okay Wow
[Music]
remember I'm good
you're great this is all one love the
flavor of this one it's a it's
definitely not happily no it's a it's
quite spicy wish I didn't let you
talking in the milk as you know Klaus we
have this recurring segment called
explain that Graham where you do a deep
dive on our guest Instagram go with you
we've pulled out some of your great old
videos okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna show you some screenshots of chili
Klaus videos and you can tell me the
story behind the video okay that's okay
that sounds good okay okay Oh what it
doesn't know all right tell me what's
going on here feeding peppers to a
thousand people at a festival no yeah
yeah
members at the town centre in Copenhagen
the capital of Denmark I just wrote a
book we celebrated it with inviting
thousand people we create the ghost
pepper and it was fantastic
there was a big music festival at the
same time called distortion Inc opening
at that time and you know kind of heavy
rock festival different kinds of and
people were running around pretending
that they were playing in the heavy rock
Orchestra because I mean
a ghost pepper exactly the same as we
did today but it was fantastic sounds
like a lovely afternoon chilly clothes
anymore yeah yeah yeah Oh with the
kitties oh they are so sweet I love
those guys
and also and say to if there are some
parents watching this show if you for
instance a little bit and out out your
teenage kid if the you know the
testicles are in his body call it and
it's not saying yeah yeah nutsack
exactly if you have a little about just
give him a Carolina Reebok coach paper
balls drop real guy pop up and then
they're quite sure that's his small I in
the nut sack it's good advice all right
oh oh that's this charming person that's
the smash man he is a kind of rude
character famous in Denmark a comedian
who yeah he's totally crazy guy
insulting his audience from the first
minute he comes in he just you know give
the F can I do that
the finger even when the Queen visited
his show this year he gave the F finger
to the Queen he he has no limits at all
it is a very very funny guy do people
ever recognize you from our videos
together how does that go that goes fine
by females so friendly and they then
they love your show also in Denmark and
in Europe let's go [ __ ] here proud of
yourself till you should be proud of
yourself I'm gonna have been combative
visit you the first time blew up a
little bit yeah yeah yeah shout out to
everybody who watches and supports thank
you very much
you do not go unnoticed I appreciate you
thank you for keeping me getting out of
bed every day and going through this
[ __ ] going through this all the time
it's intimidating yeah yeah it's
beautiful
this is the chocolate boot lock yeah
have you ever had one of these do you
like them I like them very much
okay yeah you know a lot of reviewers
say that this is even tougher to endure
than the Carolina Reaper that's a lot of
people say that's what I've heard
I've heard that it should maybe be as
hot as Quran Arriba and that's maybe
because of the ignition
[Music]
listen I'm no superhero no superhero
mission so this is a good time to
mention that these peppers are coming
from pucker but yeah oh hey ah we know a
smoke and Ed curry he's the man behind
the Carolina Reaper he's the mad
scientist behind the last step and then
I know that you visited Tucker but farms
and as I understand it because Edie told
me the story he had jit down in the dirt
begging for your life yeah can you draw
back the curtain on what it's like when
smoking at curry and chili Klaus are
walking the grounds at pucker but
sampling the new harvest hey it was
fantastic you know having never seen so
many Chili Peppers I've never seen the
workers they had I will where they were
I think it's a little slow ignition on
this one I think it's a little bit of
both
yeah that's a fast ignition but then I
think the key just keeps turning oh and
what was I saying about pepper pepper it
smoking is smoking add you said it was
like Baja wa peppers and it must have
been just like heaven for you chili
Klaus he saw peppers all over the place
and that's of workers and he had a
special area with fences around it to
protect the news pieces from people
stealing them what were the events that
led up to you being in the dirt kicking
and screaming when Colin Oliva hits you
it really hits you but when I booted I
hit you it also hits you this chocolate
thing it doesn't taste anything like
chocolate Emily
okay look at it oh yeah all right chili
Klaus nice to be your soap come here we
are at the end of the road and what we
have here is a very special delivery
from smokin egg curry okay this is the
first time that this has left the farm
this mash is made with the caramel
Reaper which as its described to me it
was supposed to be way hotter than a red
Reaper okay interesting and I think
similar with our chocolate bula over
here
they say chocolate but doesn't taste
like chocolate don't know and my guess
is that this caramel Reaper is gonna
taste nothing like caramel okay as you
know it's tradition around here to dab
the last wing what we have here is a
little something called Reaper blood
okay
it's a patent pending let me see if I
get this right Noah
it's a patent pending exclusive
distillation process has never left the
farm this is how - [ __ ] - right how does
this Noah it's hot as [ __ ] okay so just
a little just a flip up Reaper Blood
Reaper blood what's up too much
Klaus ya want something wrong - yes good
nose hi hi oh this is cool
where's this coming from Noah yeah but
what's in this [ __ ] oh I think you're
doing so good and I'm so so I'm so proud
of you
and to think remember when it started
with us back in the basement at Jimmy's
43 yeah I remember I think it's a little
bit Oh what the my Scandinavian cousins
I got a chili that was hard on that much
Canadian custom that I feel like
something was lost in translation
exactly clapping my Scandinavian cousins
s yeah but but did YouTube commemorate
at large kind of took it as is you
that's probably about your actual
cousins yeah okay oh my god how do i
duck in how do i how do I just like em
teleport to my apartment there's no go
this is now I know what it's like to be
trapped on how one's yeah you know I
never really knew what it's like this
alright just my first years my friend
it's a pleasure to be
[Music]
this is crazy bird I feel like I smoke
in my chest
like India
this is every time I hang out with you
it's not on you it's on us not a good
mix together but we are bad mix bad
combination
oh I like it it's very tasty and it also
builds up a little bit about the typical
River flavor is definitely there all
right Klaus yeah
by virtue of eating peppers together you
and I have formed a bond that is
stronger than steel thank you from the
basement of Jimmy's number 43 to Central
Park and now in the studio it's like a
long-lost friend every time I see you
what is it about spicy food that brings
people together why our chilies the
ultimate connector of the human race
it's because all over the world everyone
knows what a chili pepper is and nothing
has to be explained it's just good taste
good fun and I just love the taste what
a spin shop maybe there was maybe put a
little too much add yeah maybe that's
the class yeah you know hindsight's
always 20/20 thanks a lot sure I love
you really it was so great santa clauss
it's been a pleasure being here always a
pleasure thank you as always for coming
through season 5 to the hot ones fans
it's coming at you and it's coming at
you quick assuming I survive this you
[Music]
all right I can't understand it it's I
gotta get outta here
step in the top like this yeah I was
crazy yeah Oh Thank You Honda we knew
that some old thing ah okay okay I'm
gonna leave this here not great what did
you say it's hard to like it's hard to
UM it's hard to compare really but only
those who've been to the top of the
mountain know that go to the chocolate
that's a crazy tuning yeah I love you
yeah see you next year yeah see you next
year
hello world Sean Evans coming at you to
say thank you for watching if you liked
what you saw please subscribe
we're hovering around the 3000th ranked
youtube channel in the world it has been
a childhood dream of mine to be
somewhere in the mid twos we're so close
help make an adult bald man's dreams
come true please please please jk jk no
pressure but if you do subscribe I
appreciate it